We want to, we wanted to bring a clip so we can't
we're just going to show you the episode hey
youtubers this Charlie welcome to my spoiler
review of the first episode of Joss Whedon's
agents of shield that's right I elbowed my way
through line for eight hours and was rewarded
with the very first episode of shield it wasn't
without his problems they did actually go up and
down the aisles with these laser beams pointed
in people's eyes just to make sure you weren't
recording stuff but don't worry I'm gonna do
a full review so you'll know everything that I
know I also posted the full panel footage online
too so you can find out what the actors had to
say and what Joss Whedon had to say they mostly
use the panel to talk about all the new actors on
the show obviously they're not really focusing so
much on the superheroes it's really about regular
people so think of it as more of like an office
action slash comedy just because Joss Whedon does
that so well so the setup for the episode was
actually really funny just Whedon actually came
out you know with everyone they introduced all
the actors and he said well we were gonna show
off a clip but why don't we just show you the
whole episode so obviously the audience went
crazy and that's when all the laser beams came
out Zed turn your cameras off the episode starts
off with J August Richards character and his son
and obviously this is post Avengers so we see a
lot of superheroes and his son is lingering on
a lot of these action figures so you get a lot
of imagery from the Marvel Universe and if you've
seen the clips and the teasers you see the scenes
where J August Richards rescues that person from
the burning building and just jumps you know all
the way off the top of the building to the ground
that's basically like the opening scene during
that scene Chloe Bennet who basically plays like
this tech genius on the show catches him doing
it and basically tracks them down and learns his
identity so obviously the shield agents are trying
to find J August Richards and learn who he is
and try and help him but they can't do it so they
basically need Chloe Bennet's character to help
them track them down but before they get there we
actually meet Bret Dalton's character he's kind of
like the James Bond II quarterback of the show on
the panel Joss Whedon actually said that this is
Bret Dalton's very first TV job ever so high-five
to him for landing a Joss Whedon show an ABC
show and a Marvel show as a bit of a trifecta
but we basically find out that Breton Dalton's
character is like this lone wolf character and a
big part of his art is actually learning to work
with the cord shield team which we kind of meet
throughout the course of the episode we also meet
some people from the Whedon verse which is really
cool if you remember Shepherd book from Firefly
he's actually a doctor in shield headquarters
and Cobie Smulders is in the episode two so get
excited her actually last season on How I Met Your
Mother is happening this year so there's a good
chance that she'll be in a lot of episodes going
forward next we get some references about agent
Coulson's death is actually Brett Dalton learns
that Agent Coulson isn't dead as he's brought
into the core shield team and although they don't
explain how Coulson survived there are some lines
from Cobie Smulders that lead me to believe that
he's either say like a clone with transplanted
consciousness or memories or a life model decoy
like a lot of people believe personally I think
there's more credence to the clone theory but
you can let me know what you think if you either
saw the pilot or when the episode eventually airs
know Coulson actually sends the core shield
team off to find Chloe Bennet and bring her
into the fold since she's basically set up as this
person who can be smarter than they are obviously
rather than capture her and detain her Coulson
decides that it's more effective to turn her
and turned her into a SHIELD agent one of the big
things this Chloe Bennet characters actually used
for too is is providing an inn for new viewers
into the Marvel Universe so obviously remember
this is a Disney show on a Disney Network so they
wanted to appeal to as many people as possible so
Chloe Bennet's character is basically used to
kind of explain a lot of the technical jargon
or maybe some of the Marvel Easter eggs that
people who haven't read the comics might not
understand and like I mentioned earlier this is
technically the Whedon verse even though Joss
Whedon isn't running the show he's really just an
executive producer so Chloe Bennett actually helps
provide some of the early comedic beats there's
also some scenes between her character and Bret
Dalton's character to lead me to believe that
there'll be some shipping going on this season
although if you watched a lot of just Whedon
series in the past you know sometimes it takes
a long time for those kinds of relationships to
develop so I don't think they're gonna be hooking
up anytime soon but just based on what I've seen
I kind of think that they're basically kind of
pair off eventually so as we get to learn more in
the episode about J August Richards character we
find out that he's basically just a normal guy
who lost his job due to an injury and a mystery
doctor told him that they could make him stronger
and basically the mechanism they use is the Iron
Man three extremists obviously he's really strong
now but the threat is is that if he can't control
his power so basically explode and kill a bunch
of people so he's also got this caterpillar on
his arm and even though that sheet re they don't
really explain too much how the sheet re tech
affects his extremist powers so obviously the
episode ends on a high note but we don't really
know if we're gonna see J August Richards in
the future of the series personally I think we
will see him he might not be in every episode
but they'll be tracking down different people
and all these different episodes obviously that's
basically like the core mission they're basically
like the x-files Meets Buffy so it'll be like
you know a lot of weird sci-fi stuff going on
with a lot of humorous beats I don't know how it
felt about the use of extremists in the episode
it felt like they were kind of taking the easy
path honestly I really think they did that just
because there's so much of a popular awareness
of extremists because of Iron Man 3 so I think
that was more of a strategic decision rather than
something that they thought was cool one of the
really badass characters that we meet in the show
is ming-na they don't really fully explain this
dark past or character has but we do learn that
she basically has this really dangerous history
and I think they're gonna use all of season one
just like the the Coulson survival story to kind
of explain who she is and why she is the way
she is overall I really love the show and I'm
definitely going to be watching it every week
I'll be doing weekly shield videos be sure to
subscribe them as soon as it comes it's gonna be
coming late in September so that's around the same
time that Legend of Korra comes so there's gonna
be a ton of awesome TV content on my channel so
get really excited honestly one of the big
lingering questions though is the survival
of Agent Coulson how did he survive is he a life
model decoy is the a clone is the cyborg is he's
something else let me know what you think right
below in the comments honestly I think they're
gonna take the rest of the season to explain that
mystery and it's just gonna be tied up in all this
Chitauri tech and whoever this big villain is
whether it's aim or some other evil organization
or even just a person overall the tone that I
got from Joss Whedon on the comic-con panel was
is that he's really focusing on the core cast it
has virtually nothing to do with the superheroes
in the Marvel Universe it's really about just
this core team of shield members they're just
gonna come together and try and solve these
problems together in other news I'm also going
to be doing a lot of Breaking Bad videos there's
only eight episodes left in the season and it's
going to premiere this Sunday so I'll be doing
recaps each week so get real excited you still
have time to catch up even though I'm going to
VidCon this weekend I'll try to post a Breaking
Bad preview just to catch everyone up really
quickly if you do happen to see me at VidCon be
sure to give me high five I'll totally give you a
high five back in the meantime though check out my
review of the Doctor Who 50th anniversary trailer
from Comic Con by clicking here it was totally
awesome and learn about all the new characters
that are coming to Game of Thrones season 4 by
clicking here thanks for watching high fives for
everyone vidcon high fives see you later bye!